Así es que compañeros qué queremos en El
Salvador se ha convertido en un acto de
valentía protestar contra los abusos del
gobierno de nayib bukele el país se
encuentra en estado de emergencia desde
el 27 de marzo la policía puede tener a
cualquier persona considerada sospechosa
sin una investigación preliminar la hija
de Santos lleva siete meses en prisión
acompañaba a una amiga abrió una cuenta
de ahorros cuando llegó la policía y le
pidió el documento de identidad el cual
ella lo había olvidado pero cuando la
otra muchacha hermana llegó con el
documento le dijeron que ya estaba
detenida que ahí se iba a quedar y que
ya iba a salir mi hija se llama Carla
miquel Mejía Raimundo y tiene 22 años en
un país donde el gobierno ha ido minando
poco a poco toda oposición las familias
de las víctimas tienen una última
Esperanza la iglesia
necesitamos una audiencia se lo pide el
movimiento de víctimas del régimen señor
monseñor alas en la catedral el
arzobispo era finalmente oídos sordos y
hará sus anuncios semanales sin
mencionar a los manifestantes en su
puerta aniversario
sí nos decepciona por el obispo pero por
las víctimas esto no para
durante más de 20 años El Salvador vivió
sumido en el terror de las bandas que
secuestraban extorsionaban y asesinaban
a la población durante varios años el
país fue considerado el más peligroso
del mundo uno no sabe si tenerle miedo a
las pandillas o al régimen aquí hay
familia que la pandilla le mataron dos
hijas y el régimen le tiene preso al
hijo cada quien o sea de quién nos vamos
a defender ahora es esta gangrena de
inseguridad la que el presidente nayib
bukele ha prometido erradicar por el
método fuerte una mano dura que le ha
valido un índice de popularidad superior
al 85% el estado de sección ha sido muy
bueno sí ha afectado para los
delincuentes todo este montón de
personas no lo podían ver antes aquí
casi la gente no salía mucho de sus
casas
inseguridad que había
el gobierno anuncia la construcción de
una prisión para más de 40.000 reclusos
de hecho el número de homicidios ha
descendido drásticamente pero nayib
bukele está cerrando poco a poco los
mecanismos del poder jueces del tribunal
supremo destituidos anuncio de su
candidatura para su propia sucesión la
cual es inconstitucional prensa
silenciada Juan lleva varios meses sin
dejar sus maletas nos reunimos con él en
Río de Janeiro Brasil el propio
presidente lo ha atacado en las redes
sociales Juan es un periodista y
antropólogo que lleva años estudiando
las bandas como fenómeno social
Bueno este es uno de los
ataques vía tweet del presidente bukele
a mi a mi persona donde me llama basura
y donde investigaba los vínculos entre
un funcionario del gobierno y la banda
más poderosa del país la presión pasó de
los simples tuits al acoso judicial en
el Salvador Yo tengo una investigación
abierta por crimen organizado
es justo en el momento en que
investigaba el fiscal general entonces
es una manera de hostigarnos tanto de
amenazarnos tanto que desistamos de
hacer nuestro trabajo a pesar del riesgo
Juan regresará a El Salvador antes de
final de año para reanudar sus
investigaciones con más del 1% de la
población actualmente encarcelada el
sistema penal está completamente
saturado Efraín ofrece asistencia
jurídica gratuita en esta oficina son
dos abogados y reciben entre 60 y 80
solicitudes de ayuda al día
Existen dos filtros
para dar el apoyo jurídico el primer
filtro Es que la persona realmente sea
de escasos recursos y el segundo
requisito Es que la persona detenida no
pertenezca ninguna estructura criminal
las comisarías tienen objetivos diarios
de detenciones que cumplir y las
detenciones arbitrarias para cubrir
estos cupos suelen afectar a los más
pobres esta mujer está en la indigencia
desde que detuvieron a su padre y a su
cuñado hace cinco meses Mira a mí me
duele bastante lo que estamos viendo
aquí en el Salvador Yo le digo que si yo
pudiera irme con mi familia para otro
lado me fuera porque no es justo estamos
me han destrozado toda mi familia es que
han generado
un temor terrible en toda la población
este Porque mucha gente está utilizando
también esta herramienta para denunciar
cuestiones a veces por problemas
personales que puedan tener entre
vecinos pueden llegar a decir que él
pertenece a alguna pandilla como no
investigan solo van y detienen a las
personas audiencias aceleradas en las
que cientos de casos Se revisan el mismo
día la Cruzada de nayib bukele contra la
inseguridad ha hecho que El Salvador
haya pasado de ser uno de los países más
peligrosos del mundo a uno de los más
seguros pero a Costa de excesos
autoritarios y miles de inocentes en
prisión
[Música]